welcome back everybody finger lickin
foodie tours is back with another unique
and safe dining experience
this time they've partnered with arya
and the president of the finger lickin
foodie crew is here to give us all the
details welcome back donald
hi rocky thanks for having me happy new
year happy new year and thank you again
for bringing this to the community
especially right now everybody's just
kind of looking for something to enjoy
right how did you guys
make your pandemic pivot what changes
did you make
well we are catering to locals uh
especially for date night valentine's
day
uh typically our tours we have a tour
guide and you group with other guests
that have signed up
this is exclusive to your invited party
so it's just you and your loved ones
uh whether it's friends and family that
are visiting minimum of two guests
and they have your tables set up
guaranteed reservations
you get a tasting menu from each
restaurant three dishes a total of 10
with dessert an optional maverick
helicopter flight
afterwards for an additional hundred
dollars so people are looking for a
socially distanced way
to to enjoy uh support the multiple
restaurants and have an experience
at a time like we're in that is
incredible so break it down for us this
is a new partnership how does it work
and what what does the experience
include
so the experience is available nightly
uh a
minimum of two guests it's uh every day
at five p.m
it's a two-hour foodie tour with an aria
resort casino
depending on the nights it's typically
our catch
carbon and john george steakhouse wow
when john george doesn't open then we'll
go to bardo brasserie
but it's three of the top hottest
restaurants in las vegas
uh with three signature dishes from each
let us know if you have any allergies or
dietary restrictions we have the
optional beverage package
uh come seven o'clock you have the
option or not whether you signed up for
the helicopter
flight over the strip after they'll pick
you up from arya take you to maverick
uh in a 15 minute flight over the strip
and then a ride back to your uh
back to aria available nightly minimum
of two
that look i have a birthday coming up so
this sounds amazing and how can people
actually join this experience and how
much does it cost
uh so all inclusive of gratuities to the
staff of each restaurant
it's 150 per person for 10 signature
dishes
so it's a tremendous value it's
available to book right on our website
that's when you'll be asked about any
allergies or dietary restrictions as
well as the helicopter upgrade
finger licking foodie tours dot com and
you'll also find three other self-guided
experiences
we have downtown in the fremont east
district arts district
featuring esther's kitchen as well as
chinatown which is very multicultural
you'll find some of the hottest off
strip restaurants
once you take one of the finger-licking
foodie tours you'll want to try them all
oh look i
you don't have to you don't have to tell
me anymore i'm already sold that is
incredible thank you so much donald
again for bringing this
to vegas and we will definitely be
checking you guys out thank you
thank you and come see us for
valentine's day yes we will
all right thank you so much kendall i'll
send it over to you